[موسيقى]
اذا ما كنت من سن الخامسه والاربعين
واستيقظت يوما نظرت الى المراه وجدت جسمها
كذكرها وزادت في وجهك التجاعيد التي تشعرك
ببعض الكابه وفقد تشرف فلا تشتغلين ذلك
لانك ربما اصبحت عضوا في سن الياس فاهلا
وسهلا ومرحبا
لكن ما هو سنه الرجال يتساؤل كثير من
الاشخاص عن هذه المساله ويجب العلم انها
حاله تؤثر على كبار السن مما تجاوز عمر
الشباب ولها اعراض متفاوته ترتبط بانخفاض
هرمون التجسستيرون وشيخه
ولها العديد من العوامل ومنها انخفاض
الاندروجين في الذكور وقصور الغدد
التناسليه
[موسيقى]
الاحصائيات الطبيه لنا اكثر من 40% من
الرجال في العالم يعانون من هذا المرض
الصامت او ما يمكن تسميته بازمه منتصف
العمر والتي تتمحر اعراضها بين قلق مستقبل
سواء العملي او على المستوى الشخصي الامر
الذي قد يدفع للاكتئاب والياس من الحياه
ربما تصل الى مرحله خطره اذا ما ادرك
الانسان حاله في هذه المرحله
[موسيقى]
ويبقى الامر في طبيعه الحال النسبيه بين
الرجال يعتمد على ما تكونوا عليه الحياه
التي يعيشها الرجل الذي لا ياتي لمن لم
يرضى ويقرع بحياته وتفاصيلها حتى وان بلغ
هذه السنه وقد قال الناس فيما سبق لا ياسا
مع الحياه ولا حياه مع الياس والانسان
الاختيارو بين الامر يعني صباح العربيه
محمد خالد
[موسيقى]